for as long as human beings have been
around we've been counting things and
we've been looking for ways to keep
track and represent the things that we
counted so for example if you if you
were an early human and you were trying
to keep track of the days since it last
rained you might say okay let's see it
didn't rain today so it's that's it's
one day has gone by and you know we now
use the word one but they might have not
used it back then now another day goes
by then another day goes by then another
day goes by another day goes by another
day goes by
another day goes by and then it rained
and so when his friend comes and says
well how long has it been since we last
rained well
you would say well this is how many days
it's been and your friend would say okay
i think i have a general sense of that
and at some point they probably realize
that it's useful to have names for these
so they would call that we call this one
two three four five six 7 and obviously
every language in the world has
different names for these and i'm sure
there are lost languages that had other
names for them but very quickly you
start to realize that this is a pretty
bulky way of representing numbers one it
takes a long time to write down
it takes up a lot of space and then
later if someone wants to read the
number they have to sit here and count
and it's hard enough with seven but you
could imagine if there were what we call
27 of it or or a thousand of it then it
would take up you know possibly a whole
page and and even when you count it you
might make mistakes
and to solve this
human beings have invented number
systems
and you it's something that we take for
granted you might say well isn't that
just the way you've always counted but
hopefully over the course of this video
you'll start to appreciate the beauty of
a number system and to realize that our
number system isn't the only number
system that is around the number system
that most of us are familiar with is the
base 10 number system often called the
decimal
the decimal number system
and why 10 well probably because we have
10 fingers or most of us have 10 fingers
and so it was very natural to think in
terms of bundles of tan or to have ten
symbols so however many bundles you have
you can use your maybe your fingers and
eventually your symbols to think about
how many there are
and since we needed ten symbols we came
up with
0 1 2 3 4 5
8 9. these 10 digits these are our 10
symbols that we use in the base 10
system and to just give us a little bit
reminder of how we use them
imagine the number
imagine the number 231
so 230
what does this represent
well what's neat about number systems is
we have place value
this place all the way to the right this
is the ones place this is the ones place
this literally means one one one bundle
of one so this is one
one right over here
this right over here this is in the tens
place
this is in the tens place
this sim this three here literally means
three tens so this literally means three
tens and this two here
this two here is in the hundreds place
it's in the hundreds place
hundreds place
and so this represents two hundreds
two hundreds and you add them together
and once again i'm still thinking in
base 10 you'd get 231 this is two
hundreds
plus
three tens
plus three tens plus 1.
and in our base 10 system notice every
time we move to the left we're thinking
in bundles of 10 of the space to the
right so
this is the ones place you multiply by
10 you go to the tens place you want to
you want to go to the next place you
multiply by 10 again you get the
hundreds place
if you're familiar with exponents
1 is the same thing as 10 to the 0 power
10 is the same thing
10 is the same thing as 10
to the first power so this is the tens
place three tens and a hundred is the
same thing as 10
to the second power and obviously you
could keep going on and on and on and on
that is the power of the base 10 system
so you might be curious now well what if
this wasn't a 10 here what if we did
let's just go as simple as we can you
could almost view this as a base 1
system you only have one symbol right
over here but what if we went to
something slightly more complex a base 2
system
and you'd be you'd be happy to know that
not only can we do this but the base 2
system often called the binary system
this is called the decimal system often
called the base two system off called
the binary system is the basis of all
modern computing it's underlying the
underlying mathematics and operations
that computers perform are based on
binary and in binary you have two
symbols you have zero and you have one
and the reason why this is useful for
computation is because all the hardware
that we use to make our modern computers
all of the transistors and the logic
gates they either result in a on or an
off state an on or an off state and so
what we do is you know when you when you
use your calculator whatever you might
be operating in base 10 but underlying
everything it is doing the operations in
binary but you might say well how do we
actually think in terms of binary
well we can construct similar places
here but instead of them being powers of
10 they're going to be powers of 2. so
let's set up some places here
so
all the way on the right
2 to the 0 power is still 1 so we could
still call that the ones place
then we can move to the left of that
we can move to the left of that that
would be 2 to the first power so we
could call that the twos place and i
could even write it out if i want
twos place instead of the tens place
then i could keep going instead of
instead of this space being the 10 to
the second or the hundreds place it'll
be the two to the second or the fours
the fours place and i can keep going
this
and i encourage you actually pause the
video and try to build this out for
yourself what would this be well this
would be two to the third or the eighths
place and notice every time we're doing
this we're multiplying by two every time
we go
every time we go to the left just like
we multiplied by ten here so notice
everywhere you see these tens we're now
dealing with twos let's keep going
let's keep going and then we can
actually represent this number using
binary
so let's do that so this right over here
i've already used that color
this right over here this is two to the
fourth we could call that the sixteens
place
and then
we could have i'll reuse some of these
colors this is two to the fifth we could
call this the thirty sec the
thirty-two's place
then we can go
we can go two to the sixth
two to the sixth we could call that well
we multiply by two again or two to the
sixth is sixty-four so this is
sixty-four's place tells us how many
sixty-fours we have a 0 or 1 64s and
we'll see that in a second
and then we can go over here this would
be
2 to the 7th that would be the
128s place
128 place and we could obviously keep
going on and on and on but this should
be enough for me to represent this
number and in future videos i will show
you how to do that but let's actually
represent the number it turns out that
this number in decimal can be
represented as
one
zero
one let me do that in yellow
one
in binary
and so what does this mean this means
you have one 128 plus 164 plus 132 plus
no 16s plus no eights plus no fours
sorry plus one fours
plus one two
plus one one and so you can see that
these are going to be the same thing
notice this is 1 128 so it's 128
plus 64
plus 32
well we don't have we have 0 16 0 8 so
we're not going to add those
plus 4
plus 4 1 4
plus 1 2
plus 1 1
plus 1 1 and add these together and once
again when we're doing this when i'm
writing it this way i'm kind of using
the number system that we're most
familiar with that we're most used to
doing the operations in but when you do
it you will see that this is the exact
same number as 231. that this is just
another representation one isn't better
than the other only reason why i
converted to this is this is what i'm
just used to
thinking in it's what i'm used to doing
operations in so hopefully you find that
pretty interesting this to me this was
kind of opened my mind so the power of
even our decimal system
in future videos we'll explore other
number systems and the most used ones
base 10 is obviously most is used very
heavily binary and there's also
hexadecimal where you don't have two
digits
or
not 10 digits but you have 16 digits and
we'll explore those in future videos and
how to convert between or rewrite the
different representations in different
bases